[Music]
welcome back to the 2021 director's
close-up this year for the very first
time we have introduced
television categories into the spirit
awards small acts
unorthodox little america lee eisenberg
emily gordon and kumail nanjiani steve
mcqueen
anna winger take it away i mean these
films should have been made when they
occurred they wanted to go straight into
people's homes straight into the
bloodstream
of britain really it's an anthology
series stories of immigrants who've
moved to america
every episode has a different cast a
different tone and so
we weren't sure we were going to be able
to make it different types of stories
different types of experiences
some stories take place over the course
of a week some span 15 years
trying to find the narrative through
line and there's no one
immigrant experience it was an amazing
experience we had an
amazing dialogue about jewishness among
the people
both behind the camera and on set
you write the thing that you want to see
i think that's the best